الاخبار اهلا بكم في تطور غير مسبوقه لنا
المتحدث باسم البنتاجون باتريدر فقدان
مسيره امريكيه متطوره بعد اصطدام مقاتله
روسيه بها فوق البحر الاسود واشار رايدر
الى ان المسيره كانت تقوم بمهمه استطلاع
فوق المياه الدوليه حين اعترضتها مقاتلتان
روسيتان بطريقه غير مهنيه حسب قوله وبينما
اكتفى رايدر بالتاكيد على انها طائره
استطلاع احجم البنتاجون عن الافصاح عن
المهمه التي كانت تقوم بها
وقد اعلنت واشنطن عن استدعاء سفير الروسي
لتسليمه رساله احتجاج على الحادثه وقال
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي انه جرى اتخاذ
خطوات لضمان عدم وقوع حطاء وقوع حطام
المسيره في الايدي الخطا
وفي موسكو قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
رصدت مسيره امريكيه القربى شبه جزيره
القرم تتجه نحو الحدود الروسيه وهي تغلق
نظام التعريف الخاص بها واضافه ان المسيره
الامريكيه سقطت في المياه دون التعرض لها
قالت رساله الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
تتقدم من الجهاز الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه
باخمت شرق اوكرانيا وكذا رئيس شركه فاجنر
الروسيه العسكريه الخاصه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحضر لهجوم مضاد في ضخمه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني بعد اجتماعه مع
القياده العليا للجيش انه تم اتخاذ قرار
بمواصله الحفاظ على مدينه باكموت وحمايتها
قالت شركه الروسيه للتصنيع العسكري ان
انتاج الذخيره في البلاد وصل الى مستوى
حاله الحرب وعلى ان الرئيس الروسي
صراع القائمه في اوكرانيا هدفه الدفاع عن
وجود دوله روسيه على حد قوله
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه صفقه
الغواصات الامريكيه الاستراليه البريطانيه
تنتهك معاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
وجددت الوزاره رفضها للصفقه واعتبرتها
تهديدا للامن العالمي
اعلن وزير الخارجيه
بانشائه تكتلات غير على غرار اوكوس ودفع
البنيه التحتيه للناتو الى اسيا يعد
اعلانا جادا للمواجهه لسنين طويله
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قد عقد
اجتماعا ثلاثيا مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي والبريطاني في قاعده
البحريه يهدف الاجتماع لوضع لمسات الاخيره
على اتفاقيه تزود بموجبها تزود الولايات
المتحده استراليا بغواصه تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه
[موسيقى]
وزير الداخليه الباكستانيه ان الشرطه
ستعتقل اليوم رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان وستقدمه للعداله وقد تجددت شبكاته في
لهون بين انصار خان والشرطه الباكستانيه
بعد وصول فريق من الشرطه لاعتقاله طلبه
عمران خان من انصارهم حتى لو تم اعتقاله
تم الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]